hi so today i want to talk a little bit
about motivation and if you clicked on
this video i'm guessing you probably ran
out of motivation so i want to give you
three tips for both long-term motivation
and short-term motivation to keep them
up and to for you to
continue in your journey towards your
phd
so i'm charlotte fraser a second year
phd student in computational
neuroscience
and i've been seeing around me that a
lot of my fellow phd students
do struggle a lot with motivation myself
included so that's why i wanted to dive
into this topic today so the first thing
i want to make really clear is that for
me there's a super distinct separation
between long-term motivation and
short-term motivation so short-term
motivation is this motivation that we
feel that we really want to start our
project and keep on going etc etc but
this type of motivation is by my
experience really fickle so it could be
that it's there some days but it could
also be that you have to work without it
and one thing that i realized pretty
quickly in my phd is that it's not
necessarily motivation that gets the
work done but it's more discipline and
habits so in the book atomic habits by
james clear
he talks about these atomic habits that
people should have every day to make
progress
and once i read this book i really
started to think about an atomic habit
that i want to set for my phd
so i decided that the most important
thing for me to finish my phd
is to do my coding every single day so
my coding work is the main part of my
phd so i try to block in a focus block
of around
three hours every day and really only
work on coding so i'm only allowed to do
that i'm not allowed to do research or
lectures or read some papers
because although this is really
important i think
during your phd it's so easy to just get
lost in this and just to
keep on doing this kind of
procrastination work and feeling really
productive but in the end of the day you
haven't accomplished something
so think about what your main part of
your thesis is going to be about and it
could be coding or it could be
literature research or it could be
doing some data experiments
and try to make those the main focus of
your day and on a related note my second
tip is to
keep these short term goals so try to
when you have your entire phd in front
of you it may seem like this super big
monster but trust me if you cut it up
into tiny parts it is doable
so try to think of what you can do
this week this month and today and
really try to make
your entire phd as small as possible so
really divide it up into tiny chunks and
see what can i do today
and how can i make the best of my day or
time today and i think by doing this you
kinda
relax a little bit and allow yourself to
just work without stressing too much
about the entire product
and my last tip is more related to
stress
so for me personally when i'm under a
lot of stress i actually have a hard
time thinking clearly so for me it works
a lot better to just take a step back
go for a walk or go for a run do a
little exercise when i feel i cannot
focus or have
no motivation to focus
so i think if you are feeling really
negative things it's okay to take a step
back and to just
see your research from a distance
and by taking a walk for example and
just thinking it over in a different
environment you perhaps find the
solution that you're stuck on or refined
your motivation to keep on working
towards your
next tiny goal
so yeah secondly i want to talk a little
bit about long-term motivation
and i think long-term motivation is very
much correlated to our
why so why are we doing our phd why did
we start what do we want to do after and
all these more existential kind of
thoughts
so until now i've seen different types
of reasons why people lose their
long-term motivation and perhaps you can
recognize yourself in one of them and i
will try to give you a solution so the
first one i want to talk about is
imposter syndrome so imposter syndrome
is this
deep sense or this feeling that you're
somewhere where you're actually not
allowed to be
or you're faking it and that people will
slowly uncover the secrets of your
identity and
will see that you're actually a false or
a fake type of person and i think this
is really prevalent amongst researchers
because our field is changing so much
and it's so
the knowledge that we have to have
is so vast nowadays that there's always
gaps
in our knowledge and i think as phd
students we finally become really aware
of what we know and what we don't know
so for me personally i came from a
background of physics
and then i studied more
artificial intelligence and a little bit
of programming and finally i transferred
towards full neuroscience but because of
this background i always felt that i was
never really good at
any one of them and all my fellow phd
students in my field have a similar type
of scattered
background so they feel very similar
that they're or not very good at
programming or they're not very good at
the neuroscience
stuff or they're not very familiar with
the biology
so i think because as a phd student you
finally realize
how much you don't know
you feel this sense of imposter syndrome
and for me a solution towards this was
just kind of accepting
that i feel like this so just accepting
that i sometimes don't feel the smartest
in the room or that i sometimes feel
that my professor may think that i don't
know as much as he hopes i know and i
think once you accept this
you will also let go a little bit of the
fear that people will find out
and also it can be a motivator to learn
a lot more so if you really feel you are
not knowledgeable enough in a certain
field it could be a problem for you to
start
working more towards that field
but from my experience and also talking
with people that are a bit further down
the line this fear of imposter syndrome
never really goes away so if you have it
and you're struggling with it
just accept it and just imagine that
everyone around you feels the same and i
think this already can give some relief
and the second type of long-term
motivation problems that i see
are more related to our
why we started i think the reason why we
start at the beginning our phd can be
very different
than the reason why we continue
so for me the reason that i started and
i think for a lot of people it's similar
is that i did want to become perhaps a
professor
or continue in the field of
the university track towards
professorship but doing research and
working in this more hierarchical
field i kind of realized that this was
not what i want to be doing because
professors are actually not doing that
much research they're mostly writing
letters for funding or checking other
people's work
so they're actually not doing that much
research themselves they're more
thinking about big ideas or managing
and i kind of realized quite soon that
this wasn't what i wanted for my future
so i really had to rethink what my phd
could bring
for me and for my life
and rethinking this i kind of know now
that i want to do
more on outreach and more towards these
type of educational videos
or perhaps go into a really big research
team where i work with more people
because a phd journey is a pretty
lonely journey but i still think my phd
can give me
a lot of credit
and a lot of opportunity to learn so
many skills that will be helpful for my
future
so for example because i know i want to
do a little bit more with outreach and
also the border between ai and
society
i'm gonna go with a friend of mine to
this conference about ai and democracy
and i think for me by realizing what i
want to do in the future without with my
phd and also make better choices right
now as to what i want to do right now
and the last point i also want to touch
upon why you are maybe struggling with
your long-term motivation during your
phd is if you're really tired or really
anxious for multiple days and you also
have this tied up with your lack of
motivation these could actually be the
first signs of a burnout
and if you're feeling like this i would
really recommend you to reach out
because the problem may not be something
solvable by yourself but you kind of
need a system or
some help from the outside to guide you
towards more healthy habits or a
healthier workplace because it could
also be something outside of you that is
causing this stress and i think burnout
is just such a detrimental feeling for
us because it really is not something
that can be solved immediately and i
also made a video about it so if you are
feeling like this maybe you can check it
out and see
if that can help you a little bit but
again i want to reiterate do reach out
to someone
and talk to
your friends your family or perhaps even
a therapist so yeah please stay safe and
healthy take care of yourself
and if you have any tips or tricks for
me as to how to deal with motivation i
would love to hear them and put them in
the comments down below
and see you next time
bye